well you know we're facing
record-breaking heat 115
plus as we head into the weekend paul
rosenberg author of
real nutrition and owner of real uh
results fitness thanks again for being
here
uh that's that smoothie was pretty darn
good i'm gonna have to say
but now we want to talk about how to
stay healthy
and what you eat during the hot summer
months is a lot of that right
absolutely hydrating foods talk about
what
the way we should eat to to really stay
well during this time well
as you see here with these type of items
that are on the table eating salads
they're very light and they digest
easily
so that will also speed up your
metabolism which can aid in weight loss
okay these types of foods don't weigh
you down because they're largely
water-based
so we want we don't eat chili and
spaghetti and things like that
big steak dinners during the summer
because the heat takes a toll on your
body you already feel like slow
and sluggish right so the nutrition is
very very important and you gave us some
really good
foods here to help us beat the heat and
help our body so
talk about those foods what do they do
well like i was saying cucumber
celery bell pepper in addition to chard
they have a lot of water in them so they
digest very easily but at the same time
they're going to hydrate you okay where
something like brussels sprouts
it's still a vegetable it still has the
water but it has more fiber
okay those types of foods that are fiber
based will digest more easily okay
hence you know you you're going to eat
more often which is going to speed up
weight loss speed up your metabolism
okay so it just keeps you balanced
correct i guess
and a lot of this really is in your book
which we talked a little bit about
before but
let's talk a little bit more about that
so um i guess
really uh real nutrition you have you
have a real eating plan
in here so it's it's an a year-round
eating plan but it's very beneficial for
our hot summer heat here in the desert
correct well it's not just um people
might think of it's just a diet but
really it's
it's about making a lifestyle change and
as a result of that
this is something that you can do that's
sustainable but
most of the foods in here are about
eating really clean and light so
it helps with staying hydrated keeps
your energy levels high
that way you don't feel full and
weighted down all the time okay
a lot of a lot of times people think i
need to eat salty foods because i need
you know to put more salt in my system
if i'm sweating a lot during the summer
is that true well you should have some
sodium in your diet but people have a
tendency to eat far too much and if
they're going out to eat all the time
restaurants are putting salt and oils
and other things in food that
make it weighted down and then you can
get bloated from that okay so
yes some salt is great but you don't
want to overload on it okay
so salads that have lots of good water
packing
nutrients in them and benefits in them
the way to go for the summertime
yes and you know coupling it with a
couple of these
dressings that i found these are
outstanding this one in particular this
makoto dressing
it doesn't have a lot of sodium but
these are very light and they're kept in
the cooler section
of a grocery store so they're not you
know having all the preservatives in
them
ginger and so they have a lot of good uh
flavor
yes in them fantastic okay and so how do
people get your book and how do they get
in touch with you
they can reach us at
realresultsfitness.com or they can buy
the book
on amazon actually okay and it's called
real nutrition
real nutrition and you have to be
accountable and if you're not willing to
do that
don't call paul but call paul yeah
get the book it sounds great and thank
you great ideas and just reminding us we
need to eat right eat smart
in the hot summer months absolutely okay
thanks so much for being on appreciate
it nice to meet you